elle nicolas bonjour bonjour olivier on
va devoir trouver dans la matinale de
rtl france alors comment est ce que vous
avez vécu l'ouverture des terrasses hier
matin à bien je relis j'ai regardé
fasciné gharnata vous l'avais dit la
grande opération overlord de l'expresso
à laquelle ont participé courageusement
emmanuel macron jean castex clément
bonne jean baptiste djebbari agnès
pannier une hache et bruno le maire et
j'en oublie beaucoup alors ils sont
sortis de l'elysée de matignon ou encore
de bercy pour affronter la mitraille
médiatique et le feu nourri des flashs
de photographes en parcourant quelques
hectomètres pour atteindre au péril de
leur dignité
la table de bistrot ou un café les
attendait c'était émouvant c'était beau
comme en août 44
j'ai regardé pendant de longues minutes
sur une chaîne concurrente 500 de
bonheur en direct en fait que entre
emmanuel macron et jean castex sirotant
leur café qui souriait de nouveau à la
vie face caméra de son côté le valeureux
et solitaire bruno le maire tel un
général après une longue bataille
s'afficher sur les réseaux sociaux une
terrasse de café lisant l'équipe avec un
masque un litre de gel hydro alcoolique
sur la table faisant mention dans son
poste de cet art de vivre à la française
puis puis clément bonne à table et lui
aussi devant une fournée de
viennoiseries a fait lui aussi sa petite
photo publiée sur twitter avec son
camarade djebbari avec ce vous nous avez
manqué follement
alors pas sûr que ce soit réciproque
pour tout le monde où il vanté un bien
entendu que man band cet art de vivre
français et européens
alors comment dire à quelle bonne que
l'abus d'union européenne est mauvais
pour la démocratie et qu'il faut se
garder de la mettra tout dessin et
surtout pendant le café mais c'est quand
même formidable olivier maintenant nous
pouvons danser rire et chanter tous nos
don quichotte du corona nous le disent
dans cette allégorie caféine et nous
voilà presque sorti de l'auberge
et c'est bientôt le retour de la
bamboche pour nous pauvres français
terré depuis un an jean olivier alors
nicolas on sent chez vous de l'ironie
mais est-ce que c'est pas une façon
ludique de lancer cette nouvelle phase
de déconfinement de la part du
gouvernement est de redonner le sourire
aux français
ludique wilshere olivier tant que le
ridicule ne tue pas car les membres de
ce gouvernement qui ont imposé aux
français ces restrictions de liberté
pendant 2
moi sont venus hier donné le top départ
de ce qui ressemblait à une course de
sac dans une kermesse le masque en plus
des l'homme ils se sont mit donc en
scène à la terrasse de café avait des
selles filles des postes miel sur leurs
réseaux sociaux pour nous engager à
reprendre une vie presque normale avec
les réserves d'usagé rappelé par le
grand patron de la camisole sanitaires
nous évoquions récemment le mépris rap
époux les français notamment avec
marlène schiappa qui souhaitait que
cyril hanouna anime le débat de
l'entre-deux tours vous avez maintenant
elisabeth bornes ministre du travail qui
a faire la promo de son plan emploi pour
les jeunes encore chez hanouna ce
vendredi soir et entre les deux vous
avez 7 palanquée de ministres et de
secrétaires d'état qui sous l'oeil des
caméras nous a gratifiés d'une très
gênante opérations de sueur
communication qui confine au ridicule
café viennoiseries serveurs heureux
petites tables rondes et large sourire
pour tout le monde tout y était c'était
absolument parfait
voilà comment se montrent l'opération
overlord de l'expresso c'était une très
grosse plâtre et de communication
préparé par les services ministériels
c'est un peu comme la division leclerc
finalement que lancer à l'assaut de la
dépression populaire sans le général
leclerc me pilotée par bruno le maire et
jean castex sacs à même moins de gueule
et surtout moins de panache olivier donc
on l'entend nicolas vous pensez vraiment
que le gouvernement a exagéré sa
communication a pour cette nouvelle
phase de déconfinement alors j'irai plus
loin et je parlerai même d'overdose
d'indigestion et même d'insolation
jupitérienne c'est comme ça vous le
savez lorsqu'on est trop près du soleil
mais mon petit doigt me dit que nous
sommes pas au bout de nos surprises car
le jour où le gouvernement va devoir d
confiner les fêtes foraines et les
boîtes de nuit
on aura frédéric vidal et jacqueline
gourault clichés sur un strapontin dans
un grand huit
eric dupond-moretti au volant d'une auto
tamponneuse et jean michel blanquer air
qui dansera la macarena d'une
discothèque
ça promet d'être drôle alors quand la
communication supplante ce qu'il restait
le politique c'est que le gouvernement
n'a plus rien à dire ni à décider et
pire et pire il pense que les français
feront mais ce qu'il ya c'est à dire
absolument rien
c'est donc prêté aux français une
certaine des considérations ces mêmes
français qui doivent en ce moment
bouillir après cette communication
guignolesque alors portons cher olivier
un toast au ridicule et je finirai cet
édito par une citation du regret
c'est coluche qui disait le mois de
l'année où le politicien dit le moins de
bêtises c'est le mois de février parce
qu'il n'y a que 28 jours
bah tant mieux nous sommes on may et il
y en a trente et un merci beaucoup
nicolas un édito à retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux on vous retrouve julie
prochain dans la matinale et en
attendant nicolas on attend à vos photos
en terrasse merci beaucoup